at no point did I think the superheroes
would become such a huge part of my life
as a kid I looked at them and I saw
everything I wasn't
they had big muscles supermodel good
looks and phenomenal cosmic powers and
me I kind of looked like this except
shorter and with frizzier hair and I
never felt powerful I was always just
one big ball of nervous soft energy and
superheroes much like the bullies at
school didn't seem to have a lot of room
for that for me so I stayed away and
besides who needs superheroes when
you're surrounded by Puerto Rican women
from the Bronx my ideas were cops and
paramedics my Abuela's were seamstresses
and sold jewelry up the street and my
mom got her master's degree in education
and taught kindergarten in New York City
public schools for over 30 years so my
superheroes were sitting around the
dinner table with me and I don't know
how much time you've spent with Puerto
Rican women from the Bronx but we're
also some of the world's greatest
storytellers and I'd sit there at my
grandmother's dining room table and I'd
listened to my the women in my family
tell these wild rambunctious tales about
their about navigating their lives in
the Bronx and I wanted to be them so bad
but I wasn't tough like them either so
mostly I listened and I soaked it in and
I found myself gravitating to the soft
threads in their stories and I wrote
those down the funny
the goofy the gentle those were my in
the storytelling so much so that I wrote
a young adult novel called Juliet takes
the breath about a chubby queer Puerto
Rican girl from the brown
navigating sexuality family and identity
and on the strength of Juliet Marvel
Comics tapped me to write the solo
series for their first ever latina
lesbian superhero America Chavez listen
okay created by Joe Casey and Nick
regatta for the marvel mini-series
vengeance America Chavez has been in the
Marvel Universe for over seven years
she's tough latina and she's so strong
that she can punch portals into other
dimensions I know right and people were
so excited because finally someone who
shared her identities queer and latina
would be writing her story and I saw
that right and will also when I looked
at America I saw a young latina in
survival mode see cuz her mom's had
sacrificed themselves to the universe
when she was a kid and she'd been on her
own ever since no wonder she had to be
tough and that link that link of having
to be tough that rested heavy with me
like I said I'm from the Bronx and the
Bronx is tough tough like walking past
sidewalk memorials and dodging cop
towers on your way to the Train type of
tough when stuff happens that's bad
people are like yo you got to keep it
movin you got to keep trucking don't cry
don't let it get to you and my mom and
my Diaz and my Abuela's I never saw them
take a moment to rest or to invest in
self-care and they're soft it never left
the house and so that was the first
thing that I wanted to give to America
the thing that I wished I'd been able to
give to my Abuela's that might be us the
thing that I'm trying to give to my mom
now permission to be soft like it's okay
to sit in silence and go on a journey
just to discover yourself and your pain
will make you crumble
you will fall and you will need to ask
people for help and that's okay and that
being vulnerable is good for us but see
I didn't come to like all this
compassion and healing stuff like you
know out of nowhere and so when it came
to America's story I wanted to give her
the space to be human to mess up and to
find soft on her own so she kind of had
to quit her day job you don't I'm saying
I had to give her a superhero sabbatical
and the first thing I did was enroll her
in Justice Sonia Sotomayor University
because where else would she feel safe
and represented and liberated but a
university dedicated to the first Puerto
Rican woman nominated to the Supreme
Court of the United States in her first
class's intergalactic revolutionaries
and you and America is so excited she's
ready to show off her strength she's
ready to show off her portal punching
skills and I stripped that safety net
from her right away
and I limited her powers and I changed
up her location and shook up her world
because that is what college is like
especially if you're alone but I didn't
want America to be alone for long
and so in a homework assignment gone
totally wrong she lands on a battlefield
with the x-men because when I was in
college the Reverend Kelly brown
Douglass was my mentor and I knew that
America Chavez needed one too and who
better to mentor America Chavez than
storm the first black female superhero
and one of the most powerful members of
the x-men nobody
Desilu and storm teaches America how to
quiet her mind inside of a star portal
and when America quiets her mind she
opens up the dimensions and in that
silence she can listen for anything and
one and no one has ever offered her
silence and deep reflection as a way to
be powerful and at first she rejects it
but with storms encouragement it clicks
and America quiets the world around her
and she leans into a deep vulnerability
I mean her and storm even hug I know and
and that's because my mentors loved me
enough to encourage me to investigate
myself and my ancestors and when you're
19 how do you even know what that means
I didn't learn about the history of my
people in college I learned about the
history of my people sitting on my
grandmother's lap but she pulled out the
photo album and she named everyone that
was here and everyone still left on the
island so obviously I had to crash-land
a grandma on America Chavez and not just
any grandma a big strong luchador
grandma one that loves her enough to
take her to the ancestral plane where
America Chavez could see the history of
her people play out in the skies above
and America gets to see blood the sweat
a thorn ah the birth planet of her
grandmother and she sees it get invaded
and she sees her grandmother and her mom
flee and she also sees the joy that they
experience when their new homeland
accepts them openly and offers them
tremendous care she gets to see great
pain met with even greater compassion
and that's right alongside the
tremendous strength of her family and so
everywhere that I could write I wrote
her little love notes for her and for
all the other queer kids of color trying
to be magnificent like when you lose
yourself dig deep into your ancestry
because you will find the pieces there
and also reminders that soft
is not a pass to duck to hide to be
silent to cower soft is also a push to
hold ourselves accountable kind of like
when America lands in the world war two
and comes face to face with Hitler and
she knocks the hell out just like
Captain America did in 1941 and who knew
we'd need America Chavez to punch Nazis
in 2018 and even that that justified act
kind of wrecks her a little bit so I
made sure that she linked up with her
best friend and they talked feelings and
they go on a road trip and they sing
just a girl bye no doubt at the top of
their lungs and when - a sinister
corporation takes control of sotomayor
threatens to ban portals and almost
kills America her ancestors reach for
her because they know that she needs to
heal and it is that burst of care that
healing that gives her the fuel to
defeat Midas and reclaim herself see cuz
that myth of having to go it alone and
having to be tough doesn't serve us
America Chavez is a whole superhero and
she still needed a team of support to
help her find herself and she needed
that gentleness the type of gentleness
that is rooted in compassion and still
very much invested in justice and
liberation because it's that space where
softness and vulnerability meets
strength that we transcend our everyday
selves that we become something greater
something majestic maybe even something
super thank you
[Applause]